travis parker and kourtney kardashian
must know the camera is on them oh they
sure did
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
didn't hold back with the pda
tongue and all throughout travis parker
and kourtney kardashian
the couple attended the dustin poirier
and conor mcgregor fight on saturday
but all eyes were on courtney and
travis's makeout sesh
travis parker and kourtney kardashian
yes it's a lot of tongue too much tongue
some might say
but courtney and travis have been all
over each other since they were linked
in january
i'm just like living life anyways the
love birds took to instagram to share
more of their date night like this pic
of them playing footsies
the reality star also showed off her
glam in a hotel room
as she rocked a black velvet corset with
leather pants
she also accessorized with earrings that
read i hate you
and diamond vampire things courtney and
travis were also spotted alongside
fellow rocker machine gun kelly
and his girlfriend megan fox that was my
favorite part
a source recently told dt that the
couple are just living in the moment and
enjoying each day well courtney and
travis really recognize
now more than ever how special their
relationship is
and how fortunate they are to spend
their time together
whether it's just the two of them with
friends or with their families the
source added they could also see
themselves building a future together
in a more permanent respect whatever
happens happens
courtney has been living her best life
lately unedited
just recently the mom of three showed
off her body by wearing a
thong bikini on her lifestyle brand
pusha's instagram
the snap was posted to promote pilates
tips for an
instant butt lift but fans were more
into the reality star for not
photoshopping out her cellulite
one commenter praised courtney writing
unedited
omg i love her another shared i love
that the little dimples were kept
it's so natural and so beautiful and one
fan wrote we need more of this from
celebs
i love it one user even did a call back
to courtney's sister kim kardashian's
famous diss
writing she's the most interesting to
look at
she's the least exciting to look at
which it's safe to say that's not true
travis parker and kourtney kardashian